Ці рани ще довго нагадуватимуть Івану Гунченку про війну і наступ російської армії на Київ.
Ми з ними зіштовхнулися в лісі. Відразу до бою приступили.
Того дня нам дуже пощастило, бо з нашого підрозділу втрати були тільки два поранених - це я був і ще один хлопець.
Всі решта з цього бою вийшли неушкодженими. А втрати москалів...
Порівняно з нами там були і вбиті, і поранені. Ми змусили їх відступити.
Тобто ми свою роботу виконали з мінімальними втратами.
В Івана тяжкі поранення ніг від вибуху та двох куль.
Він - один із перших українських солдатів, які потрапили на лікування в Німеччину після нападу Росії на Україну 24 лютого.
Догляд в Україні був чудовий. Було проведено кілька операцій спільно з нами.
Але питання в тому, що для цього потрібна велика команда, потрібна відповідна інфраструктура,
якої в Україні зараз практично немає.
Загалом уже щонайменше шістьох українських солдатів пролікували в шпиталі в Аахені.
Максим Картавенко на Донбасі потрапив під обстріл з російського танка. Осколок влучив у руку.
Мій медіальний нерв пошкоджений.
Тобто рух сюди я можу зробити, а у зворотній бік - ні.
Крім цього, я ще оці два пальці не відчуваю.
Рух ніби є. Кажуть, що буде краще.
Я не скажу, що в Україні погані лікарі.
Там чудові лікарі, але просто у зв'язку з обстановкою, як ви розумієте, зараз головне врятувати людині життя.
Лікарі в Аахені вже знайомі з такими травмами.
Багато досвіду ми отримали, працюючи з пацієнтами, які приїхали з Іраку багато років тому.
Тож для нас це не є чимось принципово новим.
Про поранених дбають не тільки лікарі. Українки з Аахена заїхали привітати Івана з днем народження.
З днем народження...
Наталія працює психологом у місцевому центрі для біженців,
який допомагає тим, хто через війну був змушений залишити Україну.
Дізнавшись, що в місті на лікуванні поранені українські військові,
вона разом з іншими українками приходила підтримувати вояків.
Я думаю, що це важливо поздоровляти хлопців з днем народження.
Нещодавно був у Славка день народження. Сьогодні в Діми і Вані день народження.
Частинку нашої України (передати), тому що багато дівчат готувалися.
Дівчата пекли торт, дівчата обирали подарунки. Але, на жаль, не всі можуть прийти у лікарню.
Іванові виповнилося 37. Це коротка мить радості та відволікання від війни.
Новини важко читати з України. Тому що ти розумієш, що ти тут знаходишся, в тебе все добре,
а там літаки літають, гелікоптери. І ти не боїшся, не хвилюєшся.
В Україні зовсім по-іншому. В Україні будь-який транспорт, що літає, - це або свої, або ворог. І це лячно.
Уже кілька сотень українців доставили на лікування в Німеччину.
Серед них є як цивільні, так і військові. Після одужання Іван хоче повернутися і воювати далі.
Поранення не є тією ситуацією, яка тебе звільняє від подальшого захисту батьківщини.
Тож якщо мій фізичний стан після лікування дозволить мені далі продовжувати воювати, то я далі продовжу воювати.
На момент виходу сюжету Івана вже виписали з аахенської лікарні.
У свій день народження Іван загадав лише одне: перемоги над загарбниками.